jojo freunde bas geht hertz will kommt
zu diesen neuen video ich habe mich
gefragt teuer wird billig was ist besser
wir stellen uns heute die frage finden
hoffentlich eine antwort lässt kommen
wir noch mal
erster stopp der libanese discounter
letzten zwei staudensellerie knoblauch
zwiebeln schenken würde
die tomaten und tomatenmark gemischtes
hackfleisch ein hühner brühl und hannah
und zu guter letzt vergessen also
supermarkt 1 fertig haben probiert so
günstig wie es geht einzukaufen und
jetzt wird's teuer
erste station von teuren einkauf
italienischer feinkost großhandel
lescaut staudensellerie zwar in möhren
knoblauch zwiebeln salat tomaten zum
selber schälen und hacken von jetta und
tanne sei eine gute flasche wein und
geflügel kommt das war auf jeden fall
schon deutlich teurer und es war erst
der anfang ab zur nächsten station
ich habe vielleicht noch viel zu europa
älter und gutes fleisch am stück zum
selbst wolfen jetzt zur zubereitung so
leute das sind also die einkäufe wir
haben ja einmal die teure variante und
die günstige variante und ich muss sagen
es hat mich ein bisschen überrascht wie
die preisdifferenz ist aber wenn wir
erst mal gucken was sind die großen
wesentlichen sachen die den unterschied
machen natürlich gemüse sellerie
karotten macht alles keinen gigantischen
unterschiedlich keine frage denkt man
aber tatsächlich habe ich gerade gesagt
die pasta hat zb wichtig einen 8 euro 50
für frische pasta 15 euro wein und was
heißt das ganze wir haben hier den preis
für unsere billige seite das sind 16 eur
94 jetzt fragt ihr euch wie viel hat das
ganze hier gekostet 61 eur 52 also in
jedem fall deutlich teurer wir finden
jetzt heraus oft auch deutlich besser
ist und fangen mit dem kochen
[Musik]
wir sehen können sie die vorbereitungen
abgeschlossen
die kombination fleisch das ist einfach
fertig und haben wir schweine und rinder
naschen jeweils 500 gramm das jagen
jetzt durch den fleischwolf macht es zum
ersten mal das wirklich ein bisschen
aufgeregt aber es wird glaube ich sehr
köstlich
[Musik]
wow was ist das bitte für ein
prachtvoller tisch zwei töpfe gleich
groß schon mal aufgestellt und wir
fangen an indem wir zunächst unsere
pancetta bzw unsere schinken würfel aus
lassen ihr habt schon gesehen das war
wirklich ein sehr schönes stück concerto
gehen wir einfach mal direkt so in den
topf hinein da kommt einfach schön
geschmack raus tönt es auch einfach raus
mit dem wir dann weiter arbeiten können
und den rest an warten könnt hier drüben
gleich spaß und mit unseren schinken
würfel alles gar nicht so super viel
bewegen weil wir wollen natürlich dass
das auch schöne reststoffe bekommt das
ist wichtig in der anfangsphase der
bolognese reststoffe zu generieren
sobald das einmal kopf es ist vorbei das
wirkt als wäre ist deutlich weniger
dabei ist frei ist genau die gleiche
menge also 125 zusammen waren jetta 125
gramm schinken würfel ein klein wenig
olivenöl kommt auch noch dazu
ich sage euch das ganze haus hier wird
neidisch sein auf den geruch liegt jetzt
schon geisteskrank und sobald erst mal
die böse köchelt an und dann sobald das
ganze ein bisschen ausgelassen ist
können wir auch schon hergehen und ein
teil von unserem packt fleisch nehmen
das so zu machen planen von und auch
hineingeben warten warten warten mit dem
wänden einfach damit wir auch an das
hackfleisch schöneres darum bringen
deshalb habe ich auch schon die beiden
teller bereitgestellt und können wir
nicht gleich einfach alles schon mal
raus nehmen wenn es angebraten und ruhen
da überhaupt nicht schlimm das soll
nicht durch sein das kann in der mitte
komplett roloff sein geht nur um diese
resta rom und wir holen jetzt die erste
chance einmal raus wie concerto kann
sogar noch ein bisschen brauner werden
und ihr seht alles was hier auf den
boden von top ist gibt uns richtig
schöne arm
ich habe nicht noch mal was darum gesagt
leute zu bringen hier und er auch schon
mal raus ihr merkt schon es kann ruhig
zugehen weil dieser schritt aber es ist
absolut wichtig guck mal hier rein
deshalb lohnt sich das ganze deshalb
kann man sich auch schon mal die bude
voll rauchen das gibt wirklich geboren
die parteilinken nicht direkt noch ein
bisschen runter gehen mit der hitze sagt
und jetzt schaut mal auf den topfboden
so soll das ganze aussehen so darf das
ganze aussehen und da kommen jetzt als
erste mal unsere ziele drauf was beim
billigem fleisch aufhält ist hier an der
seite kommt wirklich das wasser raus
hatten wir überhaupt nicht bei den
frisch geworfenen teureren vielleicht
ist ein qualitätsmerkmal so olivenöl
noch mal an und zwiebeln damit die
schönen basieren können aber ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich kann eigentlich gerade
gar nicht weitermachen mit dem schritt
weil hier noch was da drin ist muss das
wasser erst mal abschnitten also auch
hier olivenöl grunz wieder merkt schon
der tisch märz langsam wir kommen der
bolognese der fertigen immer den kleinen
stückchen näher
wenn unsere zwiebel angedünstet sind
gehen auch beim staunen sellerie und
karotten hinzu und dünsten die ebenfalls
mit angst also ich will mir nichts
einbilden aber ich finde der top sich
geiler aus der teure tropfen am ende
entscheidet der geschmack aber guck auch
mal auch alleine die am topfboden sich
die rohstoffe festgesetzt ist schon ein
anderer schnack wir also da ist nicht
wenig wenig los knoblauch weil es durch
müssen paares stoffe lösen sich schon
aber die wahre arbeit macht natürlich
dann gleich der weißwein können uns
schon mal unsere tomatenmark open
vorbereiten
jetzt klopfen sie auch sagt und jetzt
pro seite so ein guter esslöffel
tomatenmark und damit thomas ifi zieren
wir jetzt alles was hier drin ist
gleichberechtigung ist richtig heiß das
riecht gut gibt schöne farbe ein
absoluter traum aber es braucht auch
deshalb brauchen wir jetzt schnell
unseren weißwein also da
250 milliliter pro seite sprich wer
besoffen
der weißwein ist größtenteils reduziert
jetzt wird es zeit für die tomaten hier
hand geschält hand geschnitten und hier
die aus der dose man sieht aber die sind
ein bisschen soße gar vielleicht ist das
auch ein geheim vorteil was sonst alles
so in der soße drin ist ein bisschen
einkaufen lassen dann kommt die brühe
raum und hühnerbrühe schwach da ist
wirklich auch ein großer
preisunterschied dafür euro 20 für
einmal nutzen quasi und hier 50 cent
glaube ich für sieben liter aber b
[Musik]
bitte mach self man den jackpot und
jetzt geben wir das fleisch hinein
gemeinsam mit dem fleisch sagt der
vielleicht auf dem teller sich gesammelt
hat alles muss hier rein weil das gibt
uns den geschmack und hier bei der bill
in fraktion ist natürlich genau das
gleiche
man muss schon sagen schon jetzt merkt
man wirklich guru haptik einfach
generell unterschiede und ich bin sehr
gespannt wie sich das geschmackliche
äußert ich mache das ganze jetzt ein
bisschen klein mit meinem fall länder
aber an sich lassen es so jetzt für
mindestens eine stunde stehen wie lange
ist letztendlich stehen last komplett
euch überlassen noch nicht so heißt weil
so leicht köcheln dann sehen uns jetzt
wahrscheinlich wenn wir die nudeln
machen so ich glaube es ist jetzt auch
wirklich soweit eineinhalb stunden haben
wir das ganze kochen lassen und guckt
einfach mal rein das hier ist die
luxusversion wir sehen es ist sehr
fluffy irgendwie von der konsistenz her
und ansonsten wenig flüssigkeit anteil
das fleisch hat die gesamte
flüssigkeitsaufnahme bzw fakturiert und
hier drüben haben wir die billig
variante also klar man sieht noch die
form klassisch von dem rinder
hackfleisch aber ansonsten kann sich das
auch wirklich sehen lassen auch wenig
feuchtigkeit und es riecht so gut in
dieser küche hier hinten haben wir schon
zwei töpfe aufgestellt einmal für
frische pasta und einmal für die fertige
pasta wie sagt der italiener so schön
dass pasta wasser muss so salzig sein
wie das meer das lassen wir uns zweimal
sagen komm italiener und seiten das
ganze kräftig hier drüben gleiches spiel
wenn mehr sein wir können uns heute
ich werde natürlich die frische passt
ein bisschen früher rein machen geht
natürlich bisschen schneller wird dann
auch hoch schwimmen und ich glaube damit
fange ich jetzt einfach mal an wird sie
nicht ganz entziehen sondern bisschen
unter al dente und dann halt noch ein
die sauce geben damit sich alles schön
verbindet so fühlt sich also 8 euro 50
passte an leute das hat mich übrigens
echt am meisten gewundert dass man 8
euro 50 p 500 gramm frische pasta sein
kann muss ich ehrlich sagen ist ein
bisschen pop aber wir geben jetzt die
fertige pasta hinein ebenfalls 500 gramm
und lassen das ganze für 7
kochen jetzt wird sich das ganze auch
ganz simpel mit salz und pfeffer dass
man wirklich die geschmacklichen
unterschiede gut erkennen kann ich habe
damit bis zum ende gewartet weil
logischerweise das reduziert ja wenn man
es am anfang als das salz bleibt drin
das wasser geht raus das knallt zu sehr
vertrauen wir dran und jetzt natürlich
noch ordentlich seis drum pancetta
salzstetter zeit aber da fehlt auf jeden
fall noch einiges dann können wir auch
endlich endlich essen leute waren
monsterprojekt heute wirklich wir sind
seit sechs stunden unterwegs mit diesem
video am kochen einkaufen aber es wird
sich glauben es ist endlich soweit
gucken wir die beiden köpfe und ich
glaube es macht keinen sinn das blind zu
fressen also als ob man sieht halt
einfach selbst gemachte nudeln bzw
frisch gemachten gewinne und
dementsprechend werde ich jetzt auf zwei
teller immer jeweils eine schöne portion
aufgeben und sind schon rege tester
hinter der kamera hier einmal luxury und
hier auf der anderen seite kriegen wir
einmal die günstige variante da wird auf
jeden fall jeder sagt bernd hier unser
frischer vom leib geschnitten parmesan
24 monate gereift schon sehr sehr nice
das ganze und drüben auch nicht gerade
günstig war einer der teureren sachen
ghana pendant also quasi auch ein
bekannter italienischer käse den wir
auch darüber direkt das ist natürlich
ein bisschen voreingenommen weil ich nur
extrem teures essen mag ja richtig
vergleicht schon mal die nudel in ihrer
farbe wird die einzelnen da hat einer
das beste rock kritiker video gesehen
dieses restaurant tester den finde ich
gut ich probiere auch erstmal hier die
einzelnen ist man den ball mini an der
kasse schon guck mir auch der
unterschied vom speck herr weiger ganz
klar das ja dass jetzt ein gericht das
hier sind drei verschiedene ingredients
nebeneinander geben
das ist normales gericht muss man sagen
normale police oder gute bolognese
ja und das hier ist so man ist es und da
musst du fortschritte halte aber nichts
von der textur ganz anderer schnack ich
finde vom geschmack ist es nicht so weit
entfernt wie schon andere ist man
schmeckt man schmidt ich weiß was du
meinst und man schmeckt mehr so die
einzelnen aromen brauchst du hast dann
beim fleisch hast du doch schon nach
geschmack von süßigkeiten oder zu
sprechen hören
vierfacher preis wie hoch ist der preis
für den ganzen topf 62 16 62
der ist mir nicht wert aber mal kann man
auch mal okay wunderbar und ich würde
auch 62 euro für einen popstar
wir haben sechs leute 500 gramm nudeln
kummer wären jetzt sich zwei ordentlich
gehäufte teller gemacht guck mal hier
den kopf hat drei sogar schon der dritte
schon weit und das immer wieder das wäre
auch für man schön koch sonntag mir auf
26 euro wert fleischlos sich unnormal
ich muss auch sagen für mich jemand der
jetzt auch ansprüche entwickelt hat an
seine neffen für mich lohnt sich das
wirklich leute interessantes experiment
heute gewährt und aufwendiges kochen
heute gewesen dankbar dass er zugeschaut
hat ja
ich habe ja nur ein wort